hey you guys it's the movie
retrospective halloween edition
because halloween is tomorrow or two
days from now if you're
a patron and you're watching this early
so as i usually did i had picked a bunch
of halloween adjacent movies
like old ones to do for this and this
was the one that came out
top in the poll just beat out the
original halloween 1978 by two votes
uh which i don't think we've reviewed
the original halloween
we did halloween three yeah i don't
think we did i don't think we have well
that's why i added it to the thing
but i'm kind of glad that a sort of
lesser-known one was picked as much as i
love halloween i feel like a lot of
people have talked about this one um
have talked about that movie and like
not a lot of people have talked about
this one which is the 1981
made for tv movie the dark knight of the
scarecrow i've never seen this one
i had never seen it either and do you
know what is crazy
um on our matinee review of lost creek
where we were talking about halloween
adjacent movies somebody in the comments
said hey speaking of uh you know
halloween adjacent movies
what was this old movie i think it was
made for tv and it was about this guy
and he was mentally challenged and he
got killed and then he comes back as a
scarecrow
and i said uh that's dark night of the
scarecrow and that is the one that we
will be reviewing this week
coincidentally
yeah and we just watched it
it's one about a lynch mob in a small
town go after this
uh [ __ ] guy mentally [ __ ] guy
because they think he killed this little
girl
and the guy that was running the lynch
mob is the same dude that played
baron vladimir harkonnen out of out of
the old dune
charles uh yeah yeah and then the guy
who played the uh
wait no no that's not him is it i think
i'm pretty sure that's him
i don't think pretty sure that's him he
just gained some weight for the for the
dune roll
i can't remember if that's pretty sure
that's it was a different dude
might be but i think that's the same guy
i may be wrong
but it looked like the same guy to me
the voice and everything
and then the dude that played the
scarecrow slash [ __ ] guys the same
guy who played
dr giggles or um the bad guy from dark
matter i'm dark man yeah his
name is uh drake i think his last name
is drake but i can't remember what his
first name is yeah i was feeling bad for
the
for for the [ __ ] guy i was like oh
well you're supposed to because he's a
good dude yeah
i was like oh man they really screwed
him over
but he comes back as a scarecrow to get
vengeance kind of like the crow
yeah and it's weird i was watching like
another review of this earlier by like i
think it's called forgotten
or forgotten something and uh they said
the same thing they said the story is
essentially like it's a revenge
story just like the crow and it's like
kind of like a revenant that comes back
and like you know
gets justice against like uh you know an
injustice also kind of like high plains
drifter
yeah a little bit yeah but not a western
a little bit like that too
now the interesting thing about this
movie which i did not know
before i put it on the list i put it on
the list because
one i was pretty sure i'd never seen it
even though i kept hearing about it
because it comes up on
like a lot of best tv movie lists and a
lot of like underrated
80s horrorless so and then when i saw
that tooby had it i said oh
that's definitely one and it's kind of
it doesn't like smack you in the face
with like
that it's set at halloween but it is
because at one point there's like a
scene at a halloween carnival where i
mean
dressed up i didn't even know it was
made for tv until you said something
it comes off as just a regular movie at
the time yeah i mean other than not
being real gory like a lot of the
you know stuff is has to be implied
obviously it doesn't have to be gory
though
yeah it didn't have to be but i said
that scene might be the only thing that
would give it away it's kind of like an
early stephen king movie
adaptation like children of the corn
type of deal but the story is better i
think
yeah you know it's funny because we just
did children of the corn yeah
so we're doing yeah
yeah so initially but one thing i didn't
know about this was that
the movie was directed by
frank defelitta who i knew because he
wrote the novel of audrey rose
okay and he also wrote the novella the
entity
okay yeah um i don't know if he yeah i
don't know if he directed the entity but
he for sure like wrote the novella that
it was based on
so i never saw the audrey rose film but
i remember as a kid that the trailer
scared the [ __ ] out of me
it's cr i read the book and i saw the
film um it's
it is kind of creepy this story it's not
like outright horror
it's just more like a like a weird like
creepy like reincarnation
story but i really liked it i haven't
seen it in a long time but the book was
really good as well would you say the
other one was the entity
the entity yeah yeah that's a good movie
like i said i see that one again
yeah i really like that movie actually
it's kind of hard to get hold of
because it's like it was one of the ones
that's on the list that i wanted to
review and it just seems like it's
whatever
that's going to be kind of a touchy
subject you know what i mean because
it's based on a real paranormal case
where you can be
raped by a ghost yeah and i remember the
i remember the movie i saw it as a kid
you know and there was like a lot of
full-on nudity kind of rape scene type
things based on what i remember
it wasn't a real body though i don't
think yeah
remember you could see invisible hands
grabbing her [ __ ] rack and [ __ ] and
remember that [ __ ] another
parapsychology tom
yeah then the parapsychology was the
pair of psychologists were trying to
trap the ghost almost got like
ghostbusters or
not really ghostbusters i guess they
were it was kind of like poltergeist
yeah yeah it's a good movie though from
what i remember i remember it being good
too
the ending was kind of wacky but it's
like other than like it kind of went in
a weird direction
yeah yeah and it had like a real uh it
was inspired by the by a real case by a
real parasite i was trying to remember
what his name was
i'm sure you ready yeah i did i did um
[ __ ] man now i can't remember it was the
poultry guys case
yeah but they like they did a completely
different thing with the
[ __ ] but yeah so all that to say that
the same guy that wrote the novella the
entity that the movie was based on
is the same guy that directed this movie
now the script for this movie
was actually intended to be a theatrical
film
but then for whatever reason cbs was
kind of like hey we want that [ __ ] so
they bought it
and uh it was actually that they wanted
it like for their halloween
their special halloween movie so i guess
it first uh you know
aired on cbs back in uh october 24th i
think it was 1981.
so this is kind of like your 70s 80s tv
actor and even movie actor like all star
cast man you will probably recognize
every single [ __ ] person in this
i think i thought even the little girl i
meant to look her up and like say but
because she looked real familiar too
like she maybe did some [ __ ] when she
got older but i'm not really sure
i thought the guy ran the lynch mob was
the same dude that did
baron harkonnen the same guy out of the
same guy who played the cop
out of salem's lot isn't that the same
guy
charles derning plays a lot of cops he
plays a mailman
in this one but he's kind of like a
vigilante mailman i guess
but i can't remember if that was him or
not because there's another actor
because when i'm thinking of baron
harkonnen i'm like
that it could be the same dude but i
don't
i don't know if it's the same dude or
not the guy who played baron harconan is
the same guy who played the cop
out of salem's lot and i just looks like
the same guy
yeah same thing i think it's the same
guy just earlier when he was younger
yeah you know and he was lighter because
when he was played
harkonnen they still had him in a fat
suit but i could tell from from his face
that he had gained some weight too
but i think they had him in a fat suit
to make him even fatter yeah
to make him look like grotesque yeah
that would have just choked yeah he's
floating the floating fat man
the floating fact that's what the
airport called him bringing that
floating fat man that's [ __ ] funny
but yeah so the story behind this one
like i said because it's a tv movie like
i said they can't show a lot of gore and
everything
but a lot of stuff in there is implied
and honestly
this is like way better than a tv movie
has any right to be
i feel like 70s and 80s were kind of
like the golden era of made for tv
movies because there was a lot of really
[ __ ] good ones that came out back
then well you can make a lot of money
from tv advertising at that time
yeah and it was like everybody was like
watching the same [ __ ] so it's just kind
of like oh it's like the
it's the special halloween movie like
over on cbs like let's watch that
we only have four channels pretty much
yeah i think in 84
i think or 81 yeah i think we only have
three or may and
three plus pbs and maybe we had fox 35
by then but
i don't think so california had access
to four channels
yeah cbs nbc abc uh
nbc did i already say nbc yeah you
already said nbc nbc abc
cbs those are the main three yeah and
then like i said you usually had like a
local pbs affiliate
because we had that that was channel 24.
i thought there was another one
and then later we got fox 35 but that
might have been
mid-80s or late our local channel at
that time was i think it was
kh-tv yeah so there was a local channel
too that was pretty big in california
i think i think most most people only
had three channels
yeah and pbs but california had four so
you didn't have much
you know right what are you going to do
read a book no right broadcast
that was all pre-cable all broadcast
yeah remember that [ __ ] [ __ ] i mean we
had
i had cable in 1981 because my dad
worked yeah but a lot of people didn't
right um but yeah so this movie
it's like it just has a really great i
mean the cinematography
is like really nice you can like tell
that they
actually like gave a [ __ ] about what
this movie looked like and it has this
really
this really nice color palette really
nice shock composition
it like really has that harvesty like
small town kind of
and an interesting two thing too is that
even though it's called dark knight of
the scarecrow a lot of it is filmed
during the day and it's still creepy
yeah you know what i mean so okay so i
never would have known it was
made for tv movie so you said something
about it that that's some that says
something to the quality
yeah most tv movies [ __ ] sucked yeah
they did
i mean but you know you got like the you
know the occasional good ones yeah
and i think the 70s and 80s were kind of
the heyday and like every now and then
you you know they had like [ __ ] duel
and [ __ ] like that this is right there
with salem's lot which is made for tv
but that way i have it on
on dvd it's [ __ ] excellent yeah shot
real well
i'm talking about the old salem's live
from the 70s yeah yeah it looked good
but yeah so the story behind this it's
set in some like small town they don't
really like say what town it is it's
just some like
rural place where like corn grows or
whatever and they still do like harvest
[ __ ]
so there's this um mentally challenged
man
uh who's named bubba i said i said his
real name but that's like his nickname
so at the beginning i kind of feel like
they were doing like a frankenstein
homage
because he's like out in the field and
he's playing with this little girl mary
lee who's like his best friend because
he's kind of like you know childlike
so he she just sees him as like another
kid so they're like singing little songs
and she's like making him
like a flower lay you know what i mean
so i kind of feel like that was very
like frankenstein
like you know like where she was putting
the flower lay on him and he put it and
then like he was trying to give her a
flower and he smushed it because he's
like didn't know his own yeah i think
the younger generations have probably
never seen that movie have no idea what
that scene is
there's a scene in them the original
frankenstein what was that from the 30s
yeah where frankenstein the
frankenstein's monster gets out
and he meets a little girl and he's
playing with the little girl he's nice
with to the little girl but
he there's a misunderstanding he
accidentally throws a girl in the water
and she drowns but she can't swim so she
drowns yeah and that's really what
started
the townspeople you know what i mean
that's what that's what alerted them to
the presence of the monster and they
[ __ ] hunted down
just to kill him over that girl he
didn't mean to kill her though i don't
think
yeah and that's she was throwing roses
in the water and they were floating it
looked pretty so he decided and he
thought that was cool and he's like hey
they're in the water let's so she could
float but she drowned yeah
so i kind of feel like that's what they
were homaging because they kind of set
up
that the two of them are friends and
then you kind of get to
charles derning's character who like i
said he's not even the sheriff or
nothing he's a mailman right
but he has decided that he is like the
head of this vigilante posse
of like these four guys one of them's a
mechanic and one of them is like a
farmer and so like some other [ __ ]
and he has just decided i don't like
that bubba
is um like has this relationship with
this little girl but he just doesn't
like
the guy because well he thinks he's
dangerous mentally
yeah he thinks he's gonna [ __ ] hurt
that little girl
yeah he's implying something sexual is
going to go down
well and i will say out outright that
they
imply in this movie that the reason that
he got so head up about it was because
he was a pedophile and was like had the
hots for that little girl
he's not i've been a project because
yeah because later on they don't like i
said they don't smack you in the face
with it
but there are a couple scenes like one
of the scenes like at the halloween
carnival
and you know [ __ ] like that and there's
a scene where he talks to um
bubba's mom where it's very strongly
implied that he is a pedophile and that
he is like
interested in making more sense makes
sense that's why he
like feels so strongly about it i like
the fact that the other guys in the
lynch mob
are kind of like guys from basically
just generic dudes from like mayberry
yeah they don't really know what what to
believe they're kind of under the
influence of this dude
yeah because he's like the main bad guy
even though the other three are like
kind of idiots for going along
we're just kind of like what you know
yeah yeah what he said yeah
yeah like straight out of mayberry like
floyd remember floyd from mayberry yeah
yeah they're kind of like that
yes yeah yeah yeah but yeah so charles
darling's character whose name is otis
otis uh hazel rig is his name and so
he's kind of like
even though he's just the mailman he
said you know no nothing against mailman
is like i like mailman they bring my
mail every day
but um but he's kind of like the the
leader of this little
group of dudes and
he has them convinced that um that bubba
is dangerous
it's implied that they beat him up
on at least one prior occasion um
because one of the other guys is kind of
like oh you know i'll beat him up and
everything but then otis is trying to
say like maybe we should do something
like more permanent wink wink wink
and like the other guy's like no man
i'll beat him up but come on like chill
out
but then it so happens that the very
same day that they have that
conversation
the little girl mary lee she gets it
into her little girl head
that she's going to she peeks through
like one of her neighbors like fences or
something and she sees like all these
really cool like a fountain and some
garden gnomes and [ __ ]
and she's all excited about it she's
like i'm gonna like break into this [ __ ]
and i was like
that little girl's outlaw check her out
so she like goes through this gap in the
fence to look at the fountains and the
gnomes and [ __ ]
um but bubba's like no i'm not gonna
that's not my house it's like i'll get
in trouble because
bubba even though he's portrayed as
mentally challenged and childlike
he is very [ __ ] aware that he can't
like put a [ __ ]
hair out of line or he's gonna get his
ass beat because it looks like it's
happened like before
so that's another thing that they imply
without really saying it outright
that he is very well aware that if if he
does something that even appears wrong
that he's going to get yeah he's not
that yeah so that's what i mean so he's
portrayed as like you know simple but
he's not that [ __ ] stupid
yeah so he knows he's like no no i can't
like go in the backyard
i don't want to be in someone else's
backyard so while she's in the backyard
farting around
like you know trespassing um she gets
attacked by a vicious dog
and then they cut away and then they
have a scene which is actually kind of a
very famous scene like for people that
uh
that like this movie and have seen this
movie of bubba like taking the little
girl like in his arms and she's all
bloody and stuff
and taking her to the um to her mom's
house and saying bubba didn't do it
yeah so you don't see what happened
okay like until you don't find out what
happened until later so you assume
that i mean you know that bubba is a
good guy so you know that he probably
didn't do anything
but it looks bad so the
lynch mob led by otis he's just kind of
like
this is like exactly what we've been
waiting for so we're gonna get a [ __ ]
he loads up all his like fat compatriots
and they
well one of them one of them's really
fat the other two are kind of skinny but
um
he's like he puts him in the truck they
get their shotguns and pitchforks and
everything like that
like woohoo we're gonna go like beat up
a mentally challenged man we're gonna go
[ __ ] kill him and that's we're heroes
or whatever
so they are under the impression
whatever reason he's a monster and he
needs to be
yeah institutionalized he can't just be
running around
and because you know they don't see the
danger they're just going to kill him
yes
which is a lot that was usually how
lynch mobs were
well yeah they were just kind of dumb
dudes and in a frenzy and
they thought they were saving the
community against evil
that's usually how that [ __ ] went down
and uh this is
how it goes down but it goes down very
wrong in this industry
it does well well that's another thing
too is that i like that the other three
guys
they were kind of like like you said
under the sway of otis the mailman
so they probably did think they were
doing the right thing they're like oh my
god
he killed this little girl because all
they saw was him like with a bloody
little girl like oh and i didn't do it i
didn't do it
and it's like so he convinces them to
like what
yeah well i was gonna say it's obvious
the message of the movie
is that mob justice all right you're
really not supposed to you're not just
be out there
killing people without any trial or jury
or anything you know what i mean that
[ __ ] can go that should not quite
wrong well self-defense is one thing
but killing some dude over something
that no one saw what happened
that's very different yeah they just
jumped to the camera
jumped to the conclusion that he did
this [ __ ] and like i said otis the
mailman
you find out later that he had a you
know ulterior motive
because he was a pedophile and he was
swaying the crowd and so he was swaying
the crowd into his direction
so basically what happens bubba like
flips out because he knows
that he's gonna get blamed like like i
said he's not he's not stupid
he knows he's gonna get blamed he runs
back home to his mom's house his and
he's like freaking out and his mom
is like okay well this is what happened
like remember last time when all this
mob
came after you because like i said this
isn't the first time um
and we played the hiding game so
then you don't really see what happens
like you assume he goes and hides
somewhere
so then like the mob has all the [ __ ]
dogs and everything and they're looking
for him
and as you can probably guess they track
him to the middle of a field where he
has dressed up like a scarecrow yeah
he's just sad man he's trying to
it's really sick and he's just saying
they're like trying to kind of hide the
crowd
and the dog didn't do it but didn't do
their
dudes bearing down on him with a gun and
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know and it was like
a long tedious scene of this guy warming
up to shoot him and he's basically
because all you could see was his big
scared eyes like they [ __ ] blast his
ass
21 times they shot him right as soon as
they get done killing him
over the radio the cut the the it was
the cops wasn't it
yeah cause she said okay stand down we
got the girl it was all just a mistake
she's fine
she's fine bubba actually saved her yeah
bubba saved her from a dog that it was
the dog that did
it and [ __ ] they're like yeah
pedo dude was like oh [ __ ] but [ __ ] i
gotta make this look like he's
attacked us he puts a pitchfork in his
like in his dead hands his dead hands
and the other dudes are like oh [ __ ] you
know what i mean that now they're
[ __ ] straight up cold-blooded
murderers
so uh yeah it's it's it's a good setup
this is just a setup we just told you
like the first what
fifty ten minutes of the movie 15
minutes of movie yeah 15-20 minutes
this is kind of the impetus for the
[ __ ] vengeance you know he kind of
comes back like the crow
yeah so you're rooting for it you're
rooting for the scare yeah you're like
kill
them yeah and uh
because they get off yeah they get off
on the f
in in you know in the trial and they did
kind of show
that there was that the town basically
most of the town
didn't really go for this [ __ ] you know
what i mean the [ __ ] the lawyers were
like no you guys committed murder
yeah that was the dna yeah the d.a knew
there was a lot of people in the town
and his mama and [ __ ] you know they knew
that the [ __ ]
that dude was killed unjustly although a
lot of people just didn't care
yeah that was in there too and then the
dudes that did it the lynch mob
they were just relieved they were
laughing yeah they're like let's go to
the bar
we got away with it yeah got you know
we're sure you know
where we beat the charges yeah they they
get
you know they pay for it though well
that's kind of the cool thing is like
that
it's the setup like that and you know
that bad shit's gonna happen because the
[ __ ] movie's called dark knight of
the scarecrow
and also they have to take bubba's mama
out of the courtroom and she's like
there's a higher justice than the law
like you're gonna get yours and [ __ ] and
you're just like oh yeah
you're gonna get a whole [ __ ] can of
supernatural whoop ass coming down on
your asses
so it's just so the rest of it is like
really good suspense because you're just
like waiting
for like how each one of them is gonna
get it yeah it's not gory kids could
watch the movie
i think yeah kids could watch probably i
mean i assumed like
a lot of people that were kids when it
came out like watched it and said it was
like really scary
yeah it is it is spooky it is kind of
spooky
and um the story is real good see this
the strength of this of this
one is uh the story the setup and the
characters
yeah because you get to know like over
the
time period because what ends up
happening like after they after the
jackasses like get off at the trial
um one of them one of the farmers he's
uh you know [ __ ] around with one of
his uh you know with some of his
equipment or something
and he looks out into this barren his
barren field and there's that [ __ ]
scarecrow sitting
way out there in the distance the same
exact one and he's just sitting there
going what the [ __ ] is that doing out
there
now at first they think that someone's
playing a trick on them like
somebody he's like nobody else was there
so first they think it's like the other
dudes like hey dude not
cool not funny um then they think maybe
it's the d.a
then they think of like you know so they
don't really like
cotton to the fact that it's like a
supernatural [ __ ]
until much like because you wouldn't you
know what i mean i would say production
quality wise you're talking about on par
with like salem's life children of the
corn
about like that the acting i think is a
little bit better yeah
i like the acting is really good in this
i like the story um
this right here this movie you could
watch it as is
it does have a certain have that retro
tone and it's like a good
retro there's shitty retro that's good
too but
and then there's but then it's just so
shitty so unwatchable this is actually
got a real good retro tone
but you could remake this movie this is
this one would you could remake this
now as long as the story was the same
yeah and the acting was just as good you
could reshoot this with some cgi
parts and a little bit more gore and
make it pg-13 it would be a hit
because i'm telling you right now one
one scene that i would have really liked
you make it like the crow there to be
gore was the one scene where that one
dude like falls into his [ __ ]
thresher
yeah the [ __ ] that is yeah but i do like
that they did everything like by
implication you know what i mean so i
thought it was like really well done the
way they did that
and like i said a lot of the first
appearances of the scarecrow
are actually in the daytime and you just
like see the scarecrow like across this
field
and for a long time like you kind of
know that it's something supernatural
but it's like the characters don't
so they just like so it's kind of the
suspense is like so
and then at first like when the guys
start getting picked off
they are they have like plausible
deniability like it could still be
accident yeah so you know what i mean
did you notice it's kind of like
um friday the 13th but with not without
the same gourd now when jason had a damn
bag on his head yeah in the second
and the second one the second one it
kind of reminded me of that
uh but without the actual slasher gore
and i think they might have been
influenced a little bit i'm not sure
if the dates if what came out first uh
friday the 13th came out in 1980
the first one yeah the second one came
out probably the next year
81 or 82. this came out in 81. all right
so maybe they might have been
slightly influenced by one another but i
feel like the bag on the head thing like
from the second
friday the 13th i always thought that
that was
um influenced by the phantom killer of
texarkana from the 40s
probably because that's what that killer
looked but i'm saying the way the
scarecrow looked it was kind of like
having jason running around a little bit
it was yeah and i will say that this is
like jason and crow combined
yeah like as far as a good guy as far as
i know
this was the first at least the full
first full-length movie
that had like a killer scarecrow so i
feel like all the
later scarecrow movies like that they
did because relationship wasn't a ton
but it is like a small sub genre
we're kind of inspired by this because
the scarecrow in this looks really
creepy
you don't see them a lot but that's good
yeah and
as i said the way they shoot it at least
until the end
the way they shoot it it's they still
have plausible deniability over whether
he's really moving or whether it's like
a supernatural or whether it actually is
somebody like playing a trick on them or
something like that
so it kind of like unfolds like slowly
like whether the [ __ ] is supernatural or
not
and i will say too that charles
derning's character otis
he just he just couldn't [ __ ] leave
well enough alone you know what i mean
it's like
they so they did this horrible thing the
[ __ ] scarecrow starts coming after me
you know he's going to be last because
he's like the main bad guy
he's got to witness it all so yeah so he
sees like all his friends getting like
you know picked off in accidents like
one by one and then finally he starts
like figuring out
and he instead of like being like oh man
i'm sorry or whatever
he just like compounds the [ __ ] error
by like killing even more people
yeah he just like goes off well
that's a good that's good writing it is
yes
they're trying to double and triple down
on the fact that this is a bad dude
yeah he's trying to like salvage likes
and it wasn't just
that one sin of [ __ ]
killing and killing us an innocent guy
that he thought was guilty i think he
did think he was guilty
but then when he came back on the radio
that he wasn't guilty he was like oh
[ __ ] but i think he did think he was
guilty i think he was
well he wanted he wanted he was
subconsciously projecting it
because that's what he was that's what i
mean i think and that's always the case
folks you know the deal
they are guilty of what they accuse you
of most of the time
but that's what i'm saying that's what i
thought was really good about this is
there was so much of it was done by
implication
like i said they don't even come right
out and say oh the dude's a pedophile
um i think it's just basically there's
one scene with him like kind of talking
to the little girl in the
at the carnival and i think um bubba's
mom like says something to him about
like i've seen you looking at that girl
or something like that but it's just
like two
really quick lines they don't like put
it in your face but then
you understand why he was so like head
up to go
after bob yeah because he wanted to
crack that little girl he figured
[ __ ] other guy did that's what i'm
saying so it's like so he was a terrible
person
so he was like just but he was so he was
assuming everyone else was as terrible
as he is
yeah which a lot of terrible people
that's where they are
[Laughter]
just get involved with them church
communities they're always accusing you
the sins that they're
that they're doing that's what i mean
well that's what i said it's like it's
like it's so it's a way of like
assuaging like blame it it's like
putting it over there you know whatever
over there and then they'll never
specifically and like i said shitty
shitty people tend to think everyone
else is shitty as well
um not all of them but a lot of them do
but i so i think that was kind of cool
that that kind of like
made this a richer experience and like
you said i like the way that
as it went on and he started like
panicking and maybe figuring out that
i don't think he believed it was
supernatural until the very very end
like when he was getting his comeuppance
yeah but um because i think he kind of
went from oh it's the d.a doing it too
he thought the little girl was doing it
which i don't know how a little girl
could have pulled off all that [ __ ] but
okay
but he thought that it was that but then
finally he like came to the realization
um but i like that he was like so
desperate to like hang on to his
life and his you know evilness or
whatever
that he just kept compounding like the
original
thing that he had done like he ends up
killing like a couple other people as
well
just to keep [ __ ] under wraps you know
what i mean
it's a good little movie it's good like
i said it's on on the back of the story
by the strength of the story itself the
writing and it's got a great atmosphere
a great atmosphere a great score
yeah um it's not like i said it's not
like halloween
in your face it's halloween adjacent it
does take place around halloween because
there is a scene where they talk about
the halloween carnival
and then later they go to the halloween
carnival and like the people are
like dancing in the most yeah horrifying
awkward way possible
like i said i'd like to see a remake of
it set in this period
not not in today's period but in the in
the night in the early 1980s and then
the early 1980s and everything yeah that
would actually be something to see
yeah because you don't see a lot of i
can't really think of a lot of scarecrow
movies i mean other than like scary
stories to tell in the dark had part
of had that kind of had a little bit of
a scarecrow story in it but that was
just like an anthology
so i don't know they don't make a lot of
scarecrow
type of movies characters are scary i
kind of do it a little bit like the crow
but keep all the characters the same
shoot it with a little bit more action
and a little bit gore in the death
scenes and man this would make a good
movie again
yeah i mean they could really i like i
said they could go they could go to town
on some of the way people
ways the dudes died at this one as long
as you had
the right guy playing the scarecrow um
you could turn this into a [ __ ] real
cool character
yeah you could sell a bunch of merch off
of that you could do a whole a whole
franchise on the back of this
maybe a fight you'd have to make him
you'd have to make him endearing but
scary at the same time kind of heroic
supernatural like the crow yeah like
because he's like
essentially like a revenant because he's
a good guy yeah he's just justice wasn't
done
so he's like well i gotta come back and
do it yeah cause you all
[ __ ] it up he's gotta be mentally slow
when he dies but when he comes back he's
he's not mentally slow anymore but he
kind of seems like he is
but he's actually pretty smart tom's
like right now i'm already
thinking about what the character is
like i could see that i could see this
because his soul comes when his soul
comes back
he's fully functioning he's like the
best version of it yeah but he still
has to have that he still has to have
the appearance of being mentally
[ __ ] yeah
okay because that's his character and
that's what the living knew him as
but he's not he's not when he comes back
and that's kind of what yeah put a
target on his back too to start with
because like i said he got his ass beat
by the townsfolk
lots of times they implied but yeah so
if you want to see a halloween adjacent
movie
really good made for tv movie from the
early 80s and if you're into that
because i really like like
made for tv movies from that era and i'm
actually shocked i had never seen this
one
um check out dark knight of the
scarecrow it is free on to be
right now so you can go watch it on
halloween
and have a good time and uh that'll do
it for this movie retrospective we will
see you on the next one
bye